مشهد عوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي يكتمل
شيئا فشيئا في اخر هذه الخطوات توجيه
العاهل السعوديه الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز دعوه رسميه للرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد من اجل المشاركه في القمه العربيه
التي تنعقد في التاسعه عشر من شهر مايو
جاري في جده ويتسلم الرئيس السوريه الدعوه
من سفير السعوديه في الاردن نايف السديري
في لقاء جمعهما بالعاصمه السوريه دمشق
وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه ان قرار دعوه
سوريا جاء انطلاقا من روابط الاخوه التي
تجمع الشعبين وحرصا على الاسهام في تطوير
العمل العربي المشترك وتعزيز الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه من جهاته شكر
الرئيس السوري العاهل السعوديه بالقول ان
انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله في السعوديه
سيعزز العمل العربي المشترك لتحقيق تطلعات
الشعوب العربيه
وتعد هذه اول دعوه تتلقاها دمشق للمشاركه
في اجتماع جامعه الدول العربيه منذ اندلاع
النزاع السوري في 2011 وكانت قمه سرت في
ليبيا عام 2010 اخر قمه حضرها الاسد قبل
تجميد عضويه بلاده في جامعه الدول العربيه
في العام ذاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات